partenaires choisis stacom tenue pour
faire rosir d'avion je compte faire un
peu de gogos dancing a pas d'accord ses
confrères kraft fait moche je suis pas
prête cette photo
et on les aime mes bras j'ai entendu et
on actionne droite gauche moi j'en peux
plus de vos têtes de chien qui t'a mans
il a 60 ans je te rappelle ouais et
alors quoi qu'est ce qui se passe à 60
ans ça y était plus une femme d mamie
nova c'est ça ces progrès sont un plan
de départs sauver maman pour ça que ça
va pas on va pas tuer papa mais pas nous
maman n'est pas un parti avec une
infirmière de 30 ans et on sait pas
depuis combien de temps dure d'histoire
c'est quoi la suite je trouvais ça sent
pas que tu avais plein air à danser
c'est quand même génial de passer des
dépressive à ce que chacun par contre
c'est bien compris 1 res équipe ouch
babylone attention chien méchant je
revois ce soir on invite à sortir s'est
amusé de bercer d'illusions une femme de
60 ans je crois que le but s'est élevé à
augmenter le moral c'est ça qu'elle
tombe amoureuse d'un mec qui s'est
fourré la moitié des dom tom
rose mais qu'est ce que tu fais là bas
comme vous je suis venu observer les
pontons
on croyait que le désir s'arrête quand
on vieillit cependant on ne veut pas
avoir cette conversation avec toi ton
très ironique d'ailleurs vu que pour les
hommes ça devient plus compliqué à
partir de 50 ans l empire des sens mais
dans un monde de demi moore